Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gürbiz. Ich bin als Assistenz der Stintätik in der Notaufnahme.
Und für den Gehirn mit Ihnen das Geschäft führen. Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Klar.
Kurse Maplaf, so erst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Iran personisch stellen.
Dann auch komisch sofort zu Iran aktuelle Beschwerden, okay?
Ja, das ist gut, ja.
Okay, beheizen Sie?
Ich heiße Maria Zimmermann.
Maria Zimmermann. Könnten Sie bitte vor und nach Namen buchten wir?
Ja, Maria, M-A-R-I-A.
Ja.
Und Zimmermann, ja, Z-I-W-M-E-R-M-A-N.
So wie Zimmermann, Zimmermann.
Ja, okay. Frau Zimmermann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 66.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 2. Mai, 56.
66.
Okay, wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin ein 70 und ich wiege 78 Kilo.
Und was für Beschwerden haben Sie für Assimaman?
Ja, ich habe seit geraumer Zeit jetzt solche Bauchschmerzen,
und zwar so im Unterbauch.
Und habe ich gedacht, ich muss mich mal bei Ihnen melden.
Die sind immer schlimmer geworden.
Das hat vor so 10 Tagen, 2 Wochen angefangen.
Und mit einmal fing es an, wehzutun.
Und jetzt geht es mir irgendwie nicht gut.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, ich bin ein bisschen fieberig.
Und da in meinem Bauch ummort, dass ich habe Blähungen.
Und das tut halt wirklich wem, mal mehr, mal weniger.
Okay, ich verstehe, aber die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Die Schmerzen sind eigentlich fast immer da.
Okay.
Deswegen schlafe ich auch nicht mehr so gut.
Und wachte inzwischen durch auf.
Und dann mache ich mir natürlich auch Sorgen, was das sein könnte.
Und ach ja, es ist echt blöd.
Okay, das ist sehr gut, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Und die Schmerzen sind plus ich aufgetreten,
oder langsam aufgetreten.
Die haben plötzlich angefangen und sind dann aber immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist Ihnen ein Auslöse erinnerlich für die Schmerzen?
Ja, also ich meinte Nahrungsaufnahme oder Bewegung.
Ja, also nach dem Essen ist es immer ein bisschen schlechter.
Und früher habe ich das schon gehabt.
Wenn ich da fettiges Essen insbesondere hatte oder so,
dann ist es mir nicht gut gegangen.
Und wenn ich mich dann, wie mich den hinsetze,
dann wird es eigentlich ein bisschen besser.
Okay, im Ruh.
Was auch, was auch ein bisschen Linderung bringt.
Ich habe zurzeit auch hin und wieder mal Durchfall.
Und da ist das so, dass wenn der Durchfall drin raus ist,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, die Schmerzen sind wieder ein bisschen besser.
Also das macht schon so ein bisschen Wellen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Duschfall aus der Survival?
Eigentlich habe ich das schon ein bisschen länger.
Dass ich mal verstopft bin und mal Durchfall habe,
das beobachte ich eigentlich schon.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin schon jahrelang.
Aber dass ich nie, also ich habe da nie solche Schmerzen dabei gehabt.
Okay, aber früher haben Sie eine Bescheverde.
Ich meinte Schmerzen.
Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich so nicht gehabt.
Aber eben diesen Dechstil zwischen Verstopfung und Durchfall,
das kenne ich wohl.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Oder haben Sie einen Arzt besucht?
Ja, ich war damals mal bei meinem Hausarzt,
aber der hat dann gesagt,
ja, da sind Sie beim Essen ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Und jetzt habe ich mal probiert,
was hatte ich denn so, so Buscopane,
das soll ja so krampflösend sein.
Das habe ich mal genommen.
Und ich nehme auch zum Schlafen dann mal Baldrian,
aber so richtig viel hat das jetzt nicht gebracht.
Okay, nehmen Sie Buscopane regelmäßig ein oder mal wieder?
Nein, nein, nein, das habe ich jetzt nur mal genommen.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, noch von früher auch von meinem Mann oder so.
Und da wusste ich, dass wir das im Haus haben.
Deswegen habe ich das jetzt mal genommen.
Aber trotzdem habe ich eigentlich weiter diese Schmerzen.
Also hat Buscopane Ihnen nicht geholfen?
Ja, nicht wirklich, nein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben schon, Arwen, Sie haben auch Fieber,
haben Sie Ihre Köpftafelöter gemessen?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, die Batterie von meinem Fieber-Tavometer ist leer.
Aber ich fühle mich tatsächlich heiß und schwitzig, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, dass der Kopf so ein bisschen glüht, ja.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, die Schmerzen sind im Unterbau.
Sind die Schmerzen eher auf der rechten Seite oder auf der linken Seite?
Oder ganz runterbau?
Ja, wenn Sie so genau fragen, da haben Sie eigentlich recht, die sind mehr auf der linken Seite, ja.
Linken Seite.
Schödra und die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nee, die sind eigentlich nur da unten im Bau, das strahlt nicht, ne?
Und nachdem Fittiken es sind verschlimmer, sich die Schmerzen stimmt?
Ja, genau.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wobei mir ist dabei irgendwie nicht schlecht oder so, ne?
Ich habe nicht so viel Hunger, aber so, dass ich so richtig sagen könnte, dass mir schlecht ist, ne?
Das habe ich nicht.
Okay, wie schmerzen Sie sich auf eine Schmerzschmerzschmerzschmerzschmerzen?
Ja, das schwankt natürlich sehr.
Also jetzt sind die nicht gerade nicht so furchtbar schlimm, jetzt sind die so bei 4, 5 vielleicht, aber so unmittelbar nach dem Essen oder bevor dann so der nächste Durchfall kommt oder so.
Da sind die auch schon ein bisschen heftiger, da sind die vielleicht so bei 6, 7.
Okay.
Aber momentan bei 4 oder 5?
Ja, das kann man aushalten gerade, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Aber ich habe gedacht, ich komme trotzdem mal vorbei.
Und Sie haben auch erwähnt, Sie leiden unter Durchfall.
Wie sieht Darstul aus?
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Oh, das habe ich nicht gesehen, aber ich habe auch nicht so genau aufgepasst.
Aber mir ist es nicht aufgefallen, dass da irgendwie frisches Blut drin ist.
Okay, Darstul ist wässrig, meinst du, oder?
Ja, oder so ganz weit eben, ne?
Ja, so dass man noch erkennt, auch, was das für Lebensmittel waren.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Bilehungen?
Ja, das ist sehr unangenehm, ja.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nee, so richtig übel ist mir nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in der Listzeit gebt, ab oder zu, genommen?
Nee, das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen.
Ich liege mich zwar so alle 14 Tage mal, aber Gewicht habe ich jetzt glaube ich nicht abgenommen, ne?
Mhm.
Waren Sie in der Listzeit im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nein, bin ich nicht gewesen.
Okay.
Und Sie haben Ihren Hausarzt besucht und welche Untersuchungen wurde bei Ihnen durchgeführt?
Ja, das war ja damals, als ich mal so ein bisschen Probleme hatte.
Da war eigentlich auch schon bekannt, dass ich ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfettwerte habe.
Und dass ich auch ein bisschen erhöhten Blutdruck habe.
Das habe ich schon lange.
Und dann hat er halt, ja, ich glaube, der hat ein Ultraschall gemacht vom Bauch.
Und hat dann gesagt, er kann nix finden und ich soll doch mal ein bisschen vorsichtiger mit Effekt sein.
Mhm.
Und hat Ihr Hausarzt-Schutuldiagnostik durchgeführt oder Darmspiegelung?
Nein, das ist lange nicht gemacht worden.
Das letzte Mal, die letzte Darmspiegelung ist bestimmt schon zehn Jahre zurück.
10 Jahre, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Aber vor zehn Jahren war alles in Ordnung.
Ja, ja, sonst hätte man ja irgendwas gemacht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Zimaman, haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Sie haben gesagt, erhöfte Blutfettwerte und hohe Blutdruck.
Und also diese Erkrankungen, haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, also jetzt wird es zwar ein bisschen weniger, aber ich habe auch leicht so Blasenentzündungen.
Vielleicht wann haben Sie Blasenentzündungen?
Das habe ich als junge Frau vor allen Dingen ganz oft.
Aber meistens habe ich das mit Wärme und viel trinken ganz gut in den Griff bekommen.
Ich habe nicht so viel Antibiotika genommen.
Und jetzt habe ich das hin und wieder und wenn ich das merke, dann trinke ich halt ganz viel und nehme die Wärmplasche.
Okay, wann haben Sie das letzte Mal Antibiotika genommen?
Das ist schon lange her, bestimmt vier Jahre, fünf Jahre.
Okay.
Und seit wann haben Sie erhöfte Blutfettwerte und hohe Blutdruck?
Ja, das ist beide schon so zehn Jahre bekannt.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme so ein Betablocker ein.
Wie heißt diese Betablocker?
Oh, das heißt glaube ich Belock Zock, aber ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie viel da drin ist.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends und dann nehme ich noch Atovastatin ein.
Welche Dosis nehmen Sie?
Das sind 20 Milligramm und dann nehme ich eine abends.
Okay, außer diese Medikamente nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente.
Wenn ich nicht schlafen kann, dann nehme ich manchmal Baldrian.
Ach so, okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, ich habe nicht mehr.
Und Frau Simavan, wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, tatsächlich hatte ich vor 20 Jahren eine Seilenglasung.
Okay.
Galambilanzen, okay.
Noch eine andere Operation wurde bei Ihnen durchgeführt?
Ne, sonst.
Ne Kinderzeit, ne, ich glaube nicht mehr.
Ist Galambilanzen Entfernung, Komplikationslosverlauf?
Ja, ja, das ist irgendwie ganz gut gelaufen.
Okay, Frau Simavan, sind Sie schon in der Wechseljahrin?
Stimmt?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Seit wann sind Sie in der Wechseljahrin?
Das fing so mit Anfang 50 an und so, dass es richtig hohe ist, ist ja Mitte 50.
Okay, ungefähr 10 Jahre.
11 Jahre, 11 Jahre, okay, ich verstehe.
Und besuchen Sie Ihren Frauen ars regelmäßig?
Ja, ja, zur Krebsversorgung, hier, ganz brav, ja.
Okay, das ist sehr gut.
Und Frau Simavan, haben Sie allergiegegenetwas?
Nicht an sich wüsste, nein, so, eigentlich kann ich alles gut vertragen.
Und Frau Simavan, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Das ist sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, sehr wenig.
Also hin und wieder mein Glas Wein am Abend oder in Gesellschaft.
Ja, also vielleicht, wenn man das mal so zusammenrechnet,
so 3-mal in der Woche, 4-mal in der Woche abends ein Bläschen Wein, ja.
Okay, Frau Simavan, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht per se nicht.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich wirklich keinen Kontakt.
Nein, das habe ich noch nie probiert.
Ja, das ist sehr gut zu hören.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe 2 Kinder, aber die sind natürlich schon Erwachsenen.
Ja, sind Sie gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Was machen Sie, beruflich, sind Sie in Rente oder?
Ja, ich bin jetzt gerade in Rente sozusagen und das ist auch gut so.
Ich habe im Autoverkauf gearbeitet und das ist natürlich etwas stressig.
Können Sie sich vorstellen.
Und da hatten wir jetzt ein bisschen Ödezeiten mit Corona
und jetzt haben wir das Problem, dass wir eben viel Beratungsbedarf haben
und dass die eben Liefer Schwierigkeiten sind.
Also das war jetzt gut, dass ich da aussteigen konnte.
Das ist sehr gut für Sie, um in Rente zu sein.
Und Frau Siemer, lebt Ihr Alternat?
Nein, mein Vater ist gestorben, der hatte Lungenkrebs
und hatte dann nachher auch noch einen Schlaganfall.
Also der war wirklich schwergeschlagen.
Also Ihr Vater ist an Lungenkrebs verstorben,
aber hatte auch noch einen Schlaganfall.
Was dann letztendlich die Todesursache war,
das ist halt zusammengekommen.
Und meine Mutter lebt noch, ist hochgetagt.
Hier hat so ein Alterszucker.
Wie alt war Ihr Vater, wenn er gestorben ist?
Wo war der?
Da war der auch schon Anfang der 80er, 84 oder so.
Das typen wir sehr leid.
Und Ihre Mutter hat Blutzuckerkrankheit, stimmt?
Ja, die hat Zuckerkrankheit, genau.
Aber so diesen Alterszucker, also nicht von Kindheit an.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Und Frau Siemer, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft, ja.
Da habe ich immer sehr drauf geachtet, ja.
Sehr gut.
Ja, Frau Siemer, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Ich habe die Frage, wie Sie sich die Körperversorgung verwendet haben,
wie Sie sich die Blut abnehmen, wie Sie sich die Stuhlprobe nehmen.
Und wie Sie sich die Haut auf die Beine verwendet haben.
Und nach dem Ergebnis vorliegen,
wie Sie sich die Beine verwendet haben,
wie Sie die Diagnose mit Ihrem Nachmachs verwendet haben.
Wie Sie sich die Ergebnisse vorliegen,
bleiben Sie bei uns zu überwachen.
Das klingt vernünftig, ja.
Ich habe Ihnen ja so viel erzählt.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich dann wieder Fragen,
wenn Sie mir die Untersuchungsergebnisse erklären.
Genau, nach der Untersuchung,
ja, nach der Untersuchung Ergebnissen werde ich noch mal schwer.
Das ist gut, ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Untersuchungsraum,
kommen wir gleich.
Ja, danke schön.
Bitte schön.
Ich habe nur eine Frage.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genauer bescheiden,
wenn Sie sich die Blut abnehmen?
Blut abnehmen.
Blut abnehmen, ja.
Alles das, was Sie.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Schriftlich kam eben die Frage nach dem Appetit rein.
Das habe ich aber eigentlich irgendwo gesagt.
Nein, ich.
Ich meine, ich habe gesagt, dass ich die Zeit...
Sie haben gesagt...
Keine Hunger hab ich.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja, Appetitloskeit, genau.
Haben Sie Freunde gefügt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, gerne.
Ich kann anfangen.
Ja, ich meine spontan.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Gürbüz.
Ich bin Assistenz der Synthetik.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin-Forschheit gemacht.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin gestartet.
Die Patienten haben keine Ausstrahlung.
Die Patienten sind bei 4, 5 von 8 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Patienten sind auf der Schmerzskala, die Druck und die Korrektur, die Krampferartik.
Die Patienten haben keine Ausstrahlung.
Was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Was könnte man da vielleicht sehen?
Ich werde auch Stilproben nehmen.
Bei Unklarheit in der Sonografie oder anderer Untersuchungen kann man auch CT des Abdomens veranlasen.
Was machen Sie, wenn die Patientin eine Damenentzündung hat?
Ich werde diese Patientinstationen aufnehmen.
Ich werde die Ausstrahlung von der Physik aufnehmen.
Für die Patientin soll die Darmschiebregelung auf alle Fälle bleiben.
Ich werde die Anägetikum verordnen.
Man kann auch die Buscopane noch einmal verordnen.
Wenn ich bei Stildiagnostik eine bestimmte RG-Bestimme kann,
kann ich Antibiotikum verordnen.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie bei Ihren Untersuchungen herausfinden.
Was mit der Frau Zimmermann tatsächlich los ist.
Dann sehen wir die Patientin auf alle Fälle morgen bei der Physik.
Ich möchte etwas sagen.